pull down gst pull down is a
important technique
for
identifying protein protein interaction
so we need to use bacterial expression
system we would use e coli and we would
use bacterial expression vectors so
basically we need two bacterial
expression vectors plasmid1 and plasmid2
in plasmid1 we would have our protein of
interest a and in plasmid2 we have our
protein of interest b protein of
interest a is actually tagged with gst
in the plasmid so gst is glutathione s
transfer is and we would transfer
transform the bacteria with both these
expression vectors
and as both of these expression vectors
have the lag z promoter and a and b are
under the control of lag z promoter we
can induce the expression of a and we
can induce the expression of b with the
help of iptg which is isopropyl thiogal
oxidase which is a variant of
allolactose and the inducer of lac
operon so by indi which would induce the
lac z promoter and would actually it
would help to
express all these protein a and protein
b so now you can see in the bigger
picture protein a is produced and it has
a gst tag and protein b also have a mbp
tag now the mvp tag is sometime used to
make the protein more soluble so in
order to detect whether a and b are
interacting with each other
that means physically interacting with
each other we have to lies the cells we
have to take the cell lysate now in
first test tube we would take the cell
lysate then we would add gsh coated
beads now gsh
is glutathione which would directly bind
to gst
now it would pull down a with itself and
now if b is interacting with a
then
uh actually
b would be also pulled down with a so in
the pull-down fraction we would expect a
and b both if they are interacting with
each other then we would do
we would run the jail then we would do a
western blot
and we can use antibody against the tag
or we can use the antibody against the
protein so now you can see in the third
lane when both a and b present we get a
strong band that means a and b
both are interacting with each other
so this is how we can understand whether
a and b are interacting or not if they
are not interacting we won't get a band
so but in this particular case they are
interacting with each other i hope you
enjoyed my video please give it a quick
thumbs up and please like and subscribe
thank you